what is a myth well a myth is a lot of
things to a lot of people but I I think
the basic way I interpret this term is
that it's a story but it's a story that
has a metaphorical Dimension so a myth
like most stories is also a metaphor and
what I mean is it's taken that way by
the audience the audience uh listening
to a fairy tale or reading a myth or
seeing a movie version of any of these
things
tends to look at it with
self-referential eye people are
profoundly self-centered and they think
everything should be about them so
they're looking for themselves in the
story or in the myth and I think the
difference between myth and story is
simply that myths have another dimension
they access us another world beyond our
normal world and this might be something
Supernatural or something uncanny it
might involve the world of fairies or
mythical creatures or the gods and the
myths tend to deal with those more
philosophical questions and almost
religious questions about why are we
here who made us how are we supposed to
align ourselves with those greater
forces than ours although I think every
story has some mythological Dimensions
to it
what is a fairy tale ah a fairy tale is
a is a specialized kind of uh story uh
sometimes you can find overlaps between
myths and fairy tales but
um I have to respect uh the scholarship
of Professor Tolkien who wrote The Lord
of the Rings books of course who was
very specific about this idea of the
world of fairy and uh said that there
there should be certain uh requirements
met or certain things need to be in the
story before we can really call it a
fairy tale and the term is used very
broadly
to incorporate things that don't have a
supernatural aspect to them but usually
it means there is some kind of
penetration of our world by another
world a world that's populated by other
kinds of spirits and creatures who have
different values and different powers
than we have
and a fairy story is a uh a story that
allows us a little light into that
darkness and uh it lets us do some
thought experiments that's how I look at
it it that it allows us to imagine what
if there was another world populated
with fairies what if there was another
world where Giants lived and where
people could fly and live forever and so
forth uh these are kind of uh
speculations that we like to put into
story form and imagine uh what what
would it be like if these things were
real
how have classic myths and fairy tales
influenced a contemporary storytelling
oh I think that the classic myths and
the fairy tales have had a huge impact
um I would say one of the strongest
vehicles for this was of course the Walt
Disney Company because Walt Disney
himself
had a certain kind of faith in the fairy
tales that there was something of value
something meaningful in them and
um he sort of elevated them
into another kind of art form when he
started doing things like Snow White
which was building on other work he had
done in short cartoons where he would
address or give you an interpretation of
some well-known fairy story but um
he really went for it with Snow White
and
um it I think alerted people to the fact
that this is a kind of a mine it's it's
a a a vein that we can access and we can
pull out of that all kinds of
entertainment uh from a comic book type
stories uh to kind like profound things
that deal with the same kind of
questions or similar setups that you
find in the fairy tales but reinterpret
it for modern audiences and sometimes
put into modern dress
that can be a very entertaining and
actually useful
aspect of of making entertainment out of
fairy tales because I think this is an
important aspect of it that
these things are useful that they were
involved they were developed and they've
been cherished in the first place
because they meant something and they
were useful to people to interpret their
own lives in comparison to
these fanciful worlds that are depicted
in myths and fairy tales so people found
something useful that they could take
back into their own ordinary everyday
lives by imagining these other worlds
and comparing uh you know what's
possible in this life and what's
possible maybe in these other imaginary
worlds and I think that's just a fun
aspect of it that people like to play
these games in their minds and uh but
are also looking all the time for some
kind of meaning out of it that applies
to me you know it's again very
self-centered people will want to know
what does it mean to me at this time in
my life and there's a lot of study
that's been done about fairy tales in uh
the arena of
looking at how the fairy tale is
interpreted at different stages of life
there's a an important writer Bruno
bettelheim who wrote a book called uses
of Enchantment which is something that
the animators at Disney I know are very
aware of and he says that fairy tales
mean different things at different times
in your life and that we're constantly
you know casually but in some kind of uh
careful way going back and looking at
them again as our perspective changes as
we age so the fairy tales have this
Evergreen aspect to them that they they
come back to us they come around again
and we see them Anew and I I think that
applies on our great domestic fairy tale
The Wizard of Oz that's one that people
get something out of as a child as a
young adult as an adult and as an older
person you look back at that story and
you can still mine out of that
valuable insights
would vampire stories or stories about
witch hunts fall into the fairy tale
realm or no because some of that is
actually based on history
well I think that when we get into the
territory of vampires and werewolves and
the various monsters and creatures
zombies and things like that
um you're in the same universe as the
fairy tales because they're populated by
all sorts of monsters and scary
creatures such as I've just mentioned
but
um there is a fascination with that
um that I think is it's akin to what
people do with the fairy tales people
are very interested in the borderline
between life and death and that's one of
the issues that comes up uh in uh horror
stories that are often dealing with the
limits of life and uh maybe suggesting
to us that these boundaries that we've
been taught may not be quite so firm and
that there may be more movement along
the scale of life and death and that's
deeply disturbing to us but it's also
fascinating and it's something that we
want to study and know more about so I
think there's a lot of focus in the
culture right now on looking at the
borderline between life and death
because it's not so sharp as it used to
be and I think people are finding you
know literature and entertainment to be
ways to explore those things
all right I think you've mentioned Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein too in the
fascination with a creature that
couldn't be contained and is grotesque
but has a life of its own and can't be
stopped kind of thing yes well
Frankenstein is an interesting case
because
um I I've always related him to uh a
kind of a teenager you know that that he
has a lot of the problems that teenagers
have his body is large and it's awkward
he doesn't know what to do with it he
feels all kinds of urges that he can't
really process and so he's going through
a kind of adolescent surge uh with all
these hormones and and other chemicals
racing around in his body
and you know he wants to be free
but you know is uh restricted and and
can sometimes act out in violent ways so
uh I think you know that's one way to
read stories along the line of
Frankenstein is is that we're exploring
and reflecting back always there's a
mirror in these stories that reflects
back something that we all have had to
deal with
what are the eight common archetypes or
psychological functions found in most
stories well you know when I was sort of
composing my model of Storytelling I
looked to the work of Carl Jung who had
made this hypothesis that there is some
kind of
Collective unconsciousness
and that out of that which is like the
dreaming State or the unconscious mind
of an individual person the whole
culture has got a swirling cloud of
ideas and energies and that out of that
there were some common things that he
noticed and he called those common forms
or characters sometimes he called those
archetypes and the word means uh
a version that's very very old the
original version of something so the
archetypes are kind of uh core beliefs
or uh almost models of from which all
kinds of other variations can be
described but the ones that I found most
useful were first of all the hero who
stands for uh you know an idealized
version of ourselves uh it's somebody
who is maybe more uh
athletic or successful or bold or Brave
or uh funny or some in some way is a
little bit exaggerated
but has qualities that we would like to
have and so we project ourselves into
that hero the next one that I studied
was the mentor because I noticed that a
lot of stories like Star Wars have
strong relationships between a young
hero and an older Master like the Jedi
Masters uh the various ones that you
find in in the Star Wars saga and that
was a very interesting study how those
teachers and student
relationships uh developed and and you
could get a lot of comedy and a lot of
drama out of those the next thing would
be the shape shifters because
um it seemed as I studied many movie
examples and fairy tales and so forth
that there was often a character
who might be a love interest or a friend
or an ally for the hero but their nature
was always a little bit Shifty and they
sometimes appeared to be friendly or to
be useful allies and at times maybe
there was danger of betrayal or
disappointment so their nature is kind
of Shifting and I think that reflects
how people relate to other people
that you know you form first impressions
of people and then maybe you learn more
about them and you see they were there
was more there or less there than I
thought so uh that term shapeshifter
refers to the way that people's
appearance or their mask or their
behavior might change quite a lot in the
course of a story or in life and are
puzzling sometimes to the hero the hero
has to figure out that's one of the
tasks of the hero is to figure out who
am I really dealing with in other people
around him or her so shapeshifter is
kind of a catch-all for those and this
is where I put all of the Romantic
relationships but also the Buddy comedy
relationships that they fall into that
same pattern because typically one
member of this two-person team that's
thrown together usually one person is
pretty fixed and for term in their
appearance and their attitudes and so
forth and the other one is kind of
Shifty and untrustworthy or mysterious
and this is uh a human thing that we all
encounter we kind of know who we are to
a limited extent but we kind of have a
sense of ourselves and then we meet
other people and maybe have to work with
them and find
there's more than meets the eye so the
shape shifter is kind of a place where I
park all these romantic and
friendship and Alliance and business
kind of relationships because they do
have this aspect of of trying to figure
out who am I really dealing with
and then the next archetype I guess that
uh
comes into play is the shadow which is
the dark reflection of the hero and
I made an assumption when I started
working with these ideas that oh well
this is where we put all the villains
they're they're the Shadows they're the
dark version of the hero and when the
hero is up the villain is down and
disappointed and when the hero is in big
trouble the the villain is on top of
things and uh feels great so uh it does
cover that and and I think that's a
useful way to look at villains that
they're kind of the Dark Shadow version
of the hero but it also it's a much
bigger term in jungian
archetypal theory that includes uh all
the stuff within yourself
that you are suspicious of or you don't
trust or you don't like or you're
ashamed of or you're afraid of
traumatic events in the past that you
don't want to think about all of that
lives in an area inside of our
psychology that's called The Shadow so
it's both the name for individual
characters who might be wearing that
mask of a threat to the hero or the dark
version of the hero but it also can be a
space
within the hero or even within a society
where all that dark stuff or repressed
stuff is hidden and it has certain rules
that I think they're very interesting
for composing stories that the shadow
tends to get stronger the more you deny
it so admitting to things and revealing
things to yourself and and exploring and
dredging up
unconscious material is usually a
healthy thing it's difficult but getting
the shadow out into the light is a good
idea and I think vampires as a literary
uh creation uh are a really good
expression of that shadow idea because
technically they're supposed to uh
disappear into a puff of Ash or
something when they come out into the
sunlight and it's the same with these
shadow things they have a lot of power
when they're held down and repressed
they become quite dangerous but when you
let them out it's not so bad and they
lose their power when we shine some
light on them
so next thing up is uh very useful one
archetype that called the threshold
guardian and this is something that my
mentor Joseph Campbell wrote about
extensively and I found it really useful
in life the idea is that every time you
come to a Crossroads in life every time
you come to a boundary between one way
of living and another or one world and
another there seems to be somebody or
something there at the border guarding
that transition
and possibly blocking you like a
policeman uh stopping you uh demanding
payment
uh or telling you to go away
and uh it's one of the tasks of a hero
is learning how to deal with that and
it's inevitable these things are going
to come up sometimes it's a character in
a story sometimes it's a force like a
huge rock slide or a waterfall or
something that's blocking your path but
the heroes have to figure out ways to
get around it over it under it through
it to embrace it to seduce it to bring
it into your parade along with
everything else
and not be stopped by it that's the
basic key and I've just found this so
useful in life and in my career
that often I will meet an obstacle and I
will think this is fatal this is going
to destroy me this is going to ruin my
ambition
and then I realize no it's just a
threshold guardian and so I knowing that
I can make friends with it I can bring
it on to my side I can figure out how to
wit it or trick it uh it's it's just an
extremely useful tool in life as well as
in stories
so uh next thing up is uh a kind of
delightful archetype called the
trickster
and uh this is one that has a long long
history that goes back into myths and
fairy tales all the way back to the
earliest Tales we know from the
Egyptians and from folk stories all over
the world the idea of a funny Little
Critter who doesn't have all the cards
he's not big and scary but he's clever
or there's a lot of him like a lot of
rabbits or a lot of ants and as an
individual they don't have much power at
all but collectively they have a lot of
power and they can even be stronger or
smarter than a big creature like a bear
or something scary like that and these
stories you know have their long long
history and we still enjoy stories like
this
when I think about the Warner Brothers
cartoons about Wiley Coyote uh and uh
and the Road Runner you know the Road
Runner is uh would be helpless in the
jaws of the coyote but he never gets in
the Jaws because he's smarter than the
coyote and has a million ways of
outwitting him and using his own energy
against him uh he's he's a very clever
example of this uh this archetype of the
trickster and there are many in
different cultures uh Native Americans
talk about various creatures like the
Raven and sometimes the coyote himself
uh being the the clever one who can
outwit the the bigger scarier creatures
and it also is a place to put in your
thinking all of the clowns all of the
humor and sometimes
this is a kind of a mask that is worn by
characters in the story they become
funny in order to do some job they
become clever and are able to outwit uh
the stronger characters who who should
have all the advantages but this this
kind of trickster mentality gives them
some advantages and then
um
the the last one that uh I added in
later additions to my book it was kind
of an afterthought but it was very
important is the Ally that
um a lot of characters in stories Heroes
and stories
are limited in some way they don't have
much of a sense of humor
they are infallible or they have to be
right all the time and they really need
somebody to go alongside of them
kidding them joking with them deflating
them when they get a big ego
giving to the audience something very
important which is called comic relief
that this is a belief of Shakespeare's
is that if I'm going to clobber the
audience with really heavy emotions and
make them cry or make them horrified by
the behavior of the characters I better
leaven that just a little bit with
something funny and so he would often
put into his most serious Place uh a
little Joker character who would maybe
be a drunken guard at the gate or
an old family retainer or somebody in in
the court who was there to make fun of
the the king and the the fancy people
and I just love this uh this aspect of
allies is that sometimes they have that
comic role they overlap with the
tricksters a little bit but they bring
balance to a character and we really
really like this form of uh two people
going through a an adventure together
who are quite different they contrast
quite a lot like Sherlock Holmes is this
cold intellectual and he's balanced by
the warmth and the heart and sometimes
the foolishness of Dr Watson so the two
are not exactly mirror images they're
maybe broken mirror images of each other
but you put the two of them together and
you get a complete human being and I
think that's a great way to think about
these archetypes is that they're all
aspects of human life
and everybody has got some of these
characteristics and some of these masks
available to them and so it's a great
thing I think to study
psychology and how it comes out in the
movies and see you know what archetypes
am I expressing at this moment at this
moment I'm expressing a kind of a mentor
teacher archetype but I I may slide out
of this chair and fall down so then we'd
have the the trickster appearing
so uh you know we we have access to all
those things and that's what makes a
complete human being
and sorry did we speak about the herald
ah I knew I left one out yes it's uh
thank you for reminding me I've
forgotten uh the uh poor character The
Herald the archetype of the herald uh
maybe the reason that I left that one
out is that uh it is less
um essential than the others uh its job
can be done by any of the others but the
function sometimes is Broken Out In a
story and given to a specific
individual character
to be the one who brings the message who
usually brings the Call to Adventure and
it could be in a simple thing like a
western uh some guy comes running out of
the telegraph office and says Sheriff
the bad guys just got out of jail and
they're going to be on the train at noon
so you better gone up and be ready
because they're coming to to get you to
get the revenge and then perhaps that
character is never in the story again or
they may come back later with other
warnings but the job is that of the old
Heralds in the medieval courts who wore
a certain costume and had usually a
trumpet
to blow announcements and to say the
king is dead long live the king or the
new king or they would say there's a
princess available for marriage and we'd
like all the local princes to come
around and see which one is the best or
let's declare war or let's declare peace
or you know some important announcement
has to be made and mythologically
this goes along with
a character who flies from the world of
the Gods down to earth to bring messages
and that's Hermes
and or Mercury as the Romans called him
and that was his job but he shows up
probably more than any other character
in mythology because he was so useful he
was always flying up to heaven reporting
on things down on Earth and then sending
down the will of the gods to the heroes
and people on Earth and so he did that
Herald function very effectively
Chris can you please give us a 10-minute
version of what the hero's journey is
yes uh the hero's journey I I'm going to
give you the quick uh down a dirty
version
um there are in the way I look at it I
broke it into 12 stages and it doesn't
necessarily have to be uh chopped up
that way you could describe it in 10
stages or as Campbell did sometimes he
would take 16 or 32 because he was
interested in telling you every possible
thing that could happen but I cooked it
down into this rough outline of 12
stages because I I was trying to get
something that could be useful in many
many many cases for analyzing scripts
basically so I came up with this 12
point uh
proposal of of what the story really is
down deep so the first stage is
The Ordinary World you need to introduce
the character the main character the
story is about you have to introduce the
world they live in and let us know
what's been going on there up to this
point uh so this is like a stage that
you create on the screen and you bring
your characters out and introduce them
to the audience and show the character
doing something uh characteristic their
characteristic Behavior a way of getting
on in the world but in that opening
section there should be some kind of
clue we're going someplace else or
there's a problem here that needs to be
solved or there's a question will the
hero escape from this world will the
hero get what he or she wants will they
learn what they need
so this is an opportunity to set those
things in motion and kind of set the
table for the audience of what they need
to know to get involved and drawn into
the store Story the second bit
is the stage of Call to Adventure
because you really need to announce to
the audience that there's a problem that
needs to be solved or there's a desire
somebody has and that generates a lot of
energy in the story and draws Us in
because we are just programmed to
observe anybody even stick figure
drawings
and plug ourselves in to the desires of
that stick figure uh if if it's reaching
its little stick hands out uh to pick up
a baby or something or to get food we
automatically plug into that so the Call
to Adventure is announcing to us hey
here's somebody who's kind of like me
and
um they want something or they're in
trouble or they need something or their
world is in trouble so uh it's a way of
announcing that and I've noticed uh
there is a strong tendency to play
certain kind of music at this point they
go to the Brass section and they play
horns you'll hear a lot of horn calls
like bugle calls on the soundtrack at
this point so the composers are
instinctively going for that kind of
sound
so the next thing that typically happens
in stories is uh there's a reaction so
the Call Comes how does the hero react
and that's the third stage which is
usually refusal of the call most of the
time they put up a fight about it of
saying I don't want to go or I can't go
or I already went once and I didn't like
it there'll be some kind of statement
like this or turning away from the
adventure that's being offered and I
think this is there for a very important
reason it's to tell the audience this is
scary and your hero is naturally afraid
because he or she is being asked to go
into the unknown they don't know what's
ahead and we're all afraid of that we
might want to get out of our situation
in our Ordinary World if we're
uncomfortable as most heroes are but
uh what's next is unknown and so it's
natural to express fear and there are
some variations on this some heroes are
really into it and they want what they
want and they are just ready to go and
nothing's going to stop them but
somebody else in the design will often
jump up and say you can't do that don't
you know this is terribly dangerous
everybody who tried this was killed and
there are a lot of things in fairy tales
and myths that suggest this the hero
will be walking along the path trying to
get what he wants to get into a castle
or to rescue a princess or something
like that and notices that the ground
underneath is very crunchy and making
all this noise under his boots and he
looks down and realizes he's walking on
the bones and skulls of all the heroes
who went before and didn't make it so it
is signaling to the audience this is
serious this is dangerous and we really
need that to get involved in the story
or else we just go oh well it's you know
some cartoon or you know uh uh
string of images that I'm observing that
aren't really meaningful to me it when
we get scared for the hero then we're
involved so now we have to overcome this
fear and a typical way is stage four
introducing
um a mentor
and um the mentor is a character often
who is wiser and more involved than the
hero has been around the block once or
more times has been through the whole
hero cycle of 12 stages more than once
and uh they're there with really one job
which is to reassure the hero and give
the hero something you could equally
call this type of character a donor
character because often they give
something to the herald might be
knowledge might be a map might be a
magic sword might be a weapon or a
vehicle of some kind or just reassurance
that no I've I could I'm here to tell
you it's scary over there in this other
world but
it can be survived and I went there and
I know because you look I'm here so you
know that someone can survive this so
that often is used to give the heroes
some reassurance and there can be
stories that don't have this uh uh where
there's no mentor and that's kind of a
scary story when there's nobody to look
up to nobody to ask about what are the
rules in this other world what can eat
me what should I eat and uh you know
who's a friend and who's an enemy uh
when there's nobody to ask that's kind
of a horror story and that makes an
interesting variation and I think that's
a good point for all of these stages
that this is a very flexible system and
if you take out or leave out certain
parts it creates a very interesting
tension where the audience kind of
expects it and they want to know why
isn't that there usually that's there
and I I see there isn't any helper or
Mentor
so this is maybe a different story that
I should pay more attention to so it's
good to be Flex about these things so
next thing up stage five is now that you
have sort of
loaded up your with equipment and
reassurance and you know where you're
going you know what you want you face
your fear you've been reassured now it's
time to get up and go and when I was
working for the movie studios especially
for Disney they talked about this like
an airplane taking off and they said
you've spent all this time in what they
call the First Act the first three or
four or five movements uh those first
steps
you've loaded the plane up and you've
fueled the plane you've told everybody
to Belt their seat belts and you know
all the safety things now get the wheels
up and get the plane in the air so uh
this is the feeling of lifting up that
you get when all the preparation is
ready and now we're going into that new
world or special world as Joseph
Campbell calls it he says every story he
ever looked at seems to take place in
Two Worlds either environments or states
of being two different states of
conditions so now we're going to really
launch into that special world and this
is a big
turning point in a story that signals
the audience all the prep is done now
we're really going for it and the
audience likes that and they feel a nice
lift there and sometimes it's backed up
by changing the music or the changing
the energy of the scene to say we're
leaving Kansas we're leaving the
Ordinary World and now we're going
someplace very very different and exotic
so now you're in this special world and
you have to figure out what is special
about it so there's a stage number six
that's called tests allies and enemies
and the idea is that it's like you've
been thrown into a college class and you
don't know much about the subject but
they've given you a few chapters to read
and some problems to work out and now
you're tested but it's a small test it's
like a pop quiz that just focuses on
certain skills and abilities and so the
hero will be put through some kind of
challenges that aren't fatal necessarily
but they're a little scary and a little
dangerous and they bring attention to
the fact I don't know the rules here and
I've got to figure it out fast so I got
to figure out who can help me with this
and and who will be in my way and that's
where the allies and enemies come and
often you will find teams are built at
this stage you think about in Star Wars
the Cantina sequence where you're on the
threshold of this world of space and the
hero Luke Skywalker finds you know the
rules are very different here there's
weird creatures and quick moments of
violence so the hero is alerted that
he's going to someplace quite exotic and
different
so having been through some of those
tests there's a stage now because number
seven which I call the approach and this
is a period of time in movies and in a
lot of stories where the hero is not
quite to the center of the whole thing
yet but there's a period of traveling
there and on that travel the hero and
the rest of the team get to know each
other better and the first impressions
that you made of people and the
impression you have of yourself may
start to change because you're getting
to know them better so it's a period I
would call another name for it is
getting to know you where people develop
deeper relationships the friendships get
deeper or they get tested and you become
suspicious you might be paranoid about
the other person or you know somebody
sabotaging us and you know who is it and
you start looking around for suspects so
this is a place where comedy can develop
and where romance and Intrigue can
develop uh it's a Time
in stories where you uh sort of let your
belt out as a Storyteller and take some
time to go deeper with the characters
so this all is by way of leading up to
uh sort of the heart of the whole thing
the mainspring is stage eight which is
the ordeal and uh this is composed
really of two beats one is death or a
near-death experience or a confrontation
with death and then a rebirth that comes
out of that and it may be stretched out
over two scenes one for the death and
one for the rebirth or it can all happen
in one scene but this could be a very
drastic uh very dramatic scene often you
will have physical
combat at this stage or legal dispute or
a big argument in the family something
like that and it there's blood on the
floor and it looks like somebody's gonna
die or sometimes somebody does die and
in a lot of the myths that's exactly
what happens uh the hero actually dies
and goes into an underworld aldor is
swallowed by a creature
and you know to our eyes to ordinary
humanize is dead and over with but
they're living in this other world and
uh in the underworld or uh they get a
second shot at life and are brought back
transformed because the ordeal they went
through was so intense that it shatters
the old self and now they get to be
something different and this will
sometimes come as a surprise to the
heroes and to the audience that oh I I
didn't know I had that in me I didn't
know I could survive and face something
like that I thought that would wipe me
out and it did but I still have
something left and and I feel
differently about myself now so uh those
are are huge transformative scenes and
sometimes very violent and sometimes
very dramatic
the simple way to say it is that the
hero faces his or her greatest fear
whatever it is they're afraid of should
be established earlier in the picture uh
earlier in the show but uh at this point
they they face that fear and keep going
so the next stage number nine is reaping
the benefits of that it's called the
reward Stage Nine and here is where
sometimes you have the rebirth or this
is the aftermath of that death and
rebirth where you take some time and
reflect on what just happened and sort
of recompose yourself and begin to
experiment with this new identity that's
come because you went through a crucible
you went through something
transformative and scary and now you're
not quite the same person anymore and
you need to reflect on that and often
it's literally reflecting by looking in
a mirror there are a lot of scenes in
movies where people at this stage take a
good look at themselves and begin to
realize you know I I thought I couldn't
do the X Y or Z and you know what I can
and maybe that means I could do
something else too so they begin to
dream bigger or have a better idea of
themselves and it will often be
expressed in a long speech and
thoughtful speech where they're going
over what just happened and and
reflecting on you know when I was in the
jaws of the monster or when the bad guys
were about to beat me up uh I I had a
thought and that thought comes out and
sometimes it's a profound thing that the
hero realizes about himself or herself
so having done all this sort of
operation there is a kind of a party
atmosphere almost at this stage you
might celebrate uh on this moment of
rebirth but
um this reward phase but at some point
you kind of have to collect yourself and
the energy of the story to focus now on
finishing and this is something that
mirrors or or corresponds really well to
what goes on the life of the artist the
artist uh dives into something not
knowing what it's going to be they pull
something out of themselves that's very
intense uh they almost die doing it I
think almost every artist has that
feeling that it wasn't easy to get it
out of me but now it's out there uh it's
wonderful but now I have to publish it
now I have to bring it home now I have
to polish it and finish it so that it
can be presented and the same is true
for the heroes and the stories they
sometimes have to
rededicate themselves to finishing and
there's a increase in energy here and
often in movies you find Chase scenes at
this point where the urgency becomes
apparent that we better hurry up because
the bad guys are almost home and they're
going to claim the victory before us so
we have have to race them to get home or
the bad guys stole the treasure that we
came to get and you know we had it in
our hands but now it's gone and we have
to go chase after it or somebody we love
has been kidnapped by the villains and
we have to pursue them so the the energy
of the chase often comes up if you
looked at 100 Hollywood movies you would
find at least 80 of them have a very
exciting chasing at this point
so this is a a place where you can
almost see home but there's a lot of
trips and uh possible uh flaws and
outcomes that can yet trip you up
so uh with that increase in energy now
we come skidding into the next to last
phase number 11 which is the
resurrection which is an umbrella kind
of phrase that covers a lot of possible
operations but basically it's the climax
of the movie where uh all the questions
are brought to the fore and are answered
in one particular choice that the hero
makes or one action that the hero takes
to stand up to the villains or seize
their Birthright and there might be a
big Showdown or conflict physical fight
sword fight gunfight or courtroom battle
or big argument between the generations
but it serves to focus the heroes energy
on how have I changed them what have I
learned and I'm going to be tested here
to the Max this is the final exam stage
eight was kind of the midterm exam this
is the final and if I flunked this final
I'm doomed I'll have to either repeat it
or I'm going to end up killed so it's as
drastic as it can be but it has this
wonderful effect if the hero faces it
faces Their Fear and calls on all the
things they've learned in the story then
they end up transformed and can express
all these things they've learned in a
single action and
bring out a wonderful feeling in the
audience that the hero is now fully
realized and has learned the lessons and
has defeated the uh the bad forces
although it should look like the bad
guys are going to win and we should be
tricked almost into thinking that they
have the upper hand and then the hero
pulls out one last burst of energy or
gets help from somebody and is able to
overcome and then the final step stage
is what Campbell called return with the
Elixir and the idea here is
once you've been through such a
transformative experience that's churned
you up you have an obligation and
sometimes a desire to share it with
everybody else and that's what really
makes a hero according to Campbell's
idea of the word hero is that it's
someone who protects and serves and
doesn't do it selfishly that they do it
with a sharing kind of attitude and that
that's what really distinguishes a good
hero is that they take responsibility
for a group that they
um
step up or that they sacrifice something
at the last movement
that was very dear to them but which is
good for the community so there's often
a sense of expansion here that the
hero's little world and their little
desires and needs have a bigger
Dimension and because I went through
something dangerous and faced my fears I
have something to share I have something
to give and it might be a good story or
it might be love or it might be a new
way of doing things new idea of yourself
but it must be shared and transmitted
and that's the idea of the Elixir which
is elixir is a word from Arabic that
means a magic potion or magic dust that
has this quality like the Holy Grail of
healing all wounds or solving all
problems and uh it's a a universal
antivirus that that is everything so
that's the 12 stages as I see it and
it's a beautiful pattern that kind of
promises you if you uh
observe these things and celebrate them
in your story that don't be a payoff in
the audience that they will feel
something uh and that their life will be
shifted or their view of the world will
be shifted just a little bit and maybe
they'll have a bigger idea of what's
possible for them
how does the hero's journey help writers
develop complex characters
oh the hero's journey is really useful
for giving depth and dimension because
it asks a lot of questions uh that may
not occur to the writer at first when
you just dream up a character uh the
hero's journey suggests that there is a
back story that the hero came from
somewhere that the hero is in some kind
of a relationship to his or her world at
the beginning and that there's something
a little bit out of balance about that
and then there is a barrage of uh
impediments and obstacles and
challenging people or energies that
enter into it and make life very
complicated for the hero there's a
villain who has often who has different
Ambitions and desires than the hero
perhaps exactly contradicting with the
hero's wishes and then other characters
who have their own agendas uh some to
make fun of the hero some to give him
some grief in the Romantic department
or some other area and
so it it gives a lot of
a lot of scaffolding for people to work
out and ask questions about the heroes
I've just been doing some Consulting
on um student films in Denmark I went to
a film school there and uh also had just
been working with a Hollywood production
and uh they all want to know you know
what is the hero's journey say about my
story so they've laid out certain steps
but they want to know
um
what uh what are the possibilities
within uh the structure that they've
created so there they usually come to me
for that kind of uh alternate
possibility thinking because I've
developed by looking at thousands and
thousands of scripts uh examples I've
developed sort of a drop down menu about
everything that if you come to a certain
Crossroads uh there's one kind of
obvious thing that can happen but then
there's all these other not so obvious
things that could happen other
possibilities and I know that that list
is theoretically infinite because I keep
thinking I've come to the end of it and
I'll be watching some wonderful show
that I love and I'm thinking well I know
at this Crossroads they could do this
this this and this those are the only
four possibilities and then the
filmmaker does five six seven that I
didn't think of and I love it that's a
thrill to me to to see my pattern as I
understand it expand and you know to add
an extra decorative two of possibilities
just is a great thrill to me so I think
the the mythical mythological way of
looking at things is uh
really a practical
guidance for writers you know that uh it
it lets them think a little outside of
the box and also provide mythological
examples and that's part of how I
operate people treat me like a
mythological cash machine where you know
they put the card in and then I'm
supposed to like a ticker tape is
supposed to come out that says when
you're dealing with snakes and uh Stones
uh what kind of myths have to do with
that and then they'll listen to me tell
some ancient story that relates to it
and they'll go ah that I could do that
that's interesting you know they'll take
a piece out of some myth or fairy tale
and apply it to their let's say modern
day story and I just find that
delightful that that this old dusty
stuff still can spark things in modern
creators I think that's just terrific
what are the key elements of compelling
character ah character that's a whole
subject that
I didn't deal with very much in my
original book except in the sense of
looking at these archetypes as you know
seven or eight different aspects of uh
possibilities for characters and I'm
going at it again from a different point
of view trying to understand that word
character and as I always do I like to
excavate and go back to the original
meaning of the word when they made up
the word what were they thinking about
and what did it mean way back when so
with character you trace it back it's
actually a Greek word
spelled slightly differently but it's
the same word character
the original meaning of the word was
that a character was either the tool
that made the impression or the
impression itself like with cuneiform
lettering where you take a stick and you
make wedge-shaped marks to indicate you
know how many sheep or how many bales of
hay
that those marks or those imprints were
what they called character and then by
way of metaphor
the Greeks started thinking about well
human beings have those marks too human
beings have characters uh impressed on
them uh the the blows of Life the kind
of the good things that are dealt out
and the bad things that are dealt out
leave Impressions they leave marks on
you and then also you leave marks on the
World Around You by how you react to
what's been dealt out to you so they put
all of that together the marks the world
makes on you and the mark you leave on
the world that equals your character and
they had a very elaborate system of
understanding this which in sort of the
typical Greek way was very humanistic
what I mean is they couldn't really deal
with abstract Concepts except to put
them in human terms so if they're
dealing with an abstract concept like
justice or revenge or Excellence
uh or struggle
uh the only way they could really get a
grip on it was to turn it into a human
character and say uh let's tell some
stories about the goddess of Victory uh
the god of struggle uh the god of good
timing the goddess of luck of Fortune
the gods of Vengeance and retribution uh
the goddess of Justice
and so they they took these abstract
qualities human characteristics and
turned them into characters
that they can tell stories about and so
this is an area that I'm studying now is
um uh
what goes into making a character that
we create as an imaginary person but
also what goes into their character what
goes into making up
um the nature of of that imaginary
creation so everybody's got a character
which is a mix of the way the world sees
you like your reputation but also how
you really are inside the things you
will do and won't do the behaviors that
are your downfalls or your virtues uh
all those things go into making up your
character so this is what I'm studying
now and and looking at uh seven or eight
of those uh
gods and goddesses that are the Greek
way of understanding these human
characteristics the one I really got
started on was Arete who was a goddess
of excellence and they had they used
that word Arete to mean somebody has got
a retake they've they've got that
quality they're just excellent as a
speaker or as a law Giver or as a father
or mother
or cook you know they they just they're
really good and and that was called
Arete but then they had this story about
arrete who was a goddess
who guided people on the path of virtue
and they even made up a uh evil twin for
her who was called kakya and she was the
bad version of Excellence maybe
Excellence that is perverted uh that
you're excellent at all costs and you're
you want to be excellent at something so
much that you'll walk on other people's
heads to get there uh or that you take
the lazy way instead of the path of
difficulty and Challenge and excellence
so this is just for me a wonderful
lens you know that I use to look at
these qualities and I'm trying to gather
ideas about it to help writers to
compose
characters who have some of these
qualities and just asking themselves
asking the writers I'm asking the
writers to ask themselves
have I considered my character's
attitude towards Justice my character's
attitude towards Excellence my
character's attitude towards Revenge uh
so this is me uh the new area for me
that I'm exploring
and have you applied some of that back
onto the original example that we talked
about the Cary Grant uh character in The
Hitchcock film where you you there was
something amiss and you couldn't figure
out why he was coming at it a certain
way sure well in that uh example from
Hitchcock and notorious uh Cary Grant is
ruled by two Gods at once and one of
them is Amore the god of love or Venus
the goddess of love and he's got a
gorgeous perfect personification of
Venus right in the room there with him
calling him to give up uh this other
path but the other God that he serves is
the god of Duty and I haven't figured
out or analyzed yet what that is in the
Greek language but
um or or the cast of characters but he
is clearly torn between those two and
that's a great thing to do to a
character is to give them two gods that
they are equally bound to and but
they're in conflict and this is a great
place to to put a character so I think
Cary Grant is trying to figure out which
God he's going to serve and makes the
mistake of serving the god of Duty for
most of the movie but in the end he
realizes he's throwing away a treasure
and he sets aside the uh the the duty in
order to uh honor the god of love or the
goddess of love
how does the hero's journey apply to
storytelling well the hero's journey
applies to storytelling because it is
storytelling you know it's it's uh the
way that we have been programmed I would
say to understand what a story is and uh
this is a a difficult question to say is
this something that we have learned uh
socially because we've seen so many
stories that we have formed an idea that
every story more or less follows this
journey pattern or is it something that
is deeper than that that's hardwired
into the human nervous system and that's
kind of where I go it certainly
reinforced by seeing thousands of
examples but I think that we would
recognize the hero's journey and respond
to it in the organs of our bodies
even if we weren't acculturated to it
even if we didn't have the many examples
we would recognize it and respond to it
and and this again goes back to the
stick figure idea if you just draw stick
figures uh if they have any kind of
Desire or wish whether it's I've got a
knife and I'm going to stab this guy or
I want to give some of my food to a
starving bird
we get on board and we want what they
want or we're watchful will they do this
terrible thing or will they do this good
thing and we just can't help but be
involved so that tells me I think that
uh that the the hero's journey is uh
sort of the internal wiring diagram we
have about stories and that it's
something very very deep
is the hero's journey of formulaic
blueprint for writing a screenplay well
the question comes up
um what do you call this thing the
hero's journey is it a formula is it a
pattern is it a mode is it a paradigm I
mean there are many words that have been
applied to it
um I think the word that's being used a
lot
these days to describe other things as
algorithm and I think that's one good
way to look at it that you know an
algorithm is a sort of a numerical way
of uh analyzing things and
planning how things will progress in a
system
but I think the hero's journey is is
something like that
I don't think formula is a good name for
it because that implies that it's like a
cookbook recipe and that anybody who
puts it up there is saying well you have
to do this and you have to do that in
this sequence and this then this can
only be the next thing and this can only
be the thing after that and
I very strongly
discourage that
my point of view I guess has come around
to the idea that you must know this form
and it is a form that exists and people
know it and they recognize it
um
but you are obligated as an artist to
break that form every single time you
set out every time you write a song or
make a dance or create a story
um it's part of your obligation as an
artist to defy my expectations and
surprise me with something a combination
or leaving an element out that I've
never seen before
I'm thinking about the mentors that I
mentioned before and a kind of shocking
thing to me was a movie called Amur like
the French word for Love by a director
Michael hanaki and this won an Academy
Award for best foreign film some years
ago and it's a story about uh an older
couple
who are sort of part of the music
Intelligentsia in France and the wife
is declining with some form of Dementia
or Alzheimer's and the husband is
dealing with it and he keeps turning to
what would be in a normal story a mentor
he goes to the doctor he goes to his
daughter he goes to various nurses and
people who are there to help take care
and none of them has a clue what he
should do he doesn't have a mentor so
that peace that's normally assumed to be
present in any design story design is
just lifted out and it leaves a gap in
there that's absolutely horrifying it's
it's a horrible thing to realize you're
on your own man there's nobody who can
advise you how to deal with this
situation or if they're there they're
Hollow they're useless they don't really
serve so it's up to you and that's quite
quite chilling and horrifying they found
a wonderful beautiful way to do it but
it was a kind of psychological horror
story so uh and that's refreshing uh
because it makes you look at the whole
design in a different way like I've
assumed there must be this and this and
this what if this and this are not there
uh is that still a story uh might be and
it might be a very interesting story uh
that that is missing some pieces or
pieces are repeated sometimes that
um the economical Mind of a Hollywood
producer would say why do we have two of
those but the poetic mind says well
because it's nice to get Reflections and
to see two different characters
having the same problem and dealing with
it in slightly different ways uh that
that's uh you know an interesting
pattern that sort of breaks the formula
but does it in an interesting way
so it sounds like there were 11 then
stages but the mentor stage was taken
out of that movie and it still worked
yeah the the movie the the movie I was
referring to uh more
um still worked very well
um and I think one interpretation of it
is that the man looked outwardly for
mentors which is where you would
normally look but in fact realized the
only Mentor is on board right here I'm
it and so I'm gonna have to do something
about this situation and he does
something rather drastic
um and very dramatic and kind of scary
but uh in his universe that was the
right thing to do so uh yeah I think
that's uh
uh a way of getting off of this idea of
things being a formula I I think if you
set out to take the 12 stages as I've
described them and create a story that
hit every one of those beats you would
actually end up with a kind of a boring
trite story where people would know what
was coming because we have seen so many
examples and what we're really watching
for when we
enjoy a movie is the places where they
broke the pattern where it was it went
off and where I don't know what's
happening that I don't know why it's
happening I don't know who that is I
don't know what archetype that character
represents then I'm thrilled and I'm a
child again I go back to that childlike
State of Mind of of Wonder like what is
that just like when I was originally
read the fairy tales by my mother and
grandmother and they'd throw something
in like a giant or a A Fairy Godmother
I'd go what is that because I'd never
encountered it before so sometimes these
uh interruptions of the pattern are the
things that make it really beautiful
but that being said if someone does want
to try something different
it may be a glaring hole you may be like
well there's number three and number
eight missing and that's why it's not
working so it's kind of there's a pros
and cons there's maybe two formulaic or
stuff is not uh there's holes there's
gaps well you know there's this idea
that that a story sometimes have holes
in them that you can drive a truck
through we like to say that when we're
criticizing stories
um
but that's not always a bad thing
sometimes it's an accident of editing
that we didn't we've shot that scene
that explained that but we had to cut it
out for time or or some other uh you
know the the it rained that day and we
couldn't use the footage or something
didn't match
um but that can create again this very
interesting tension in the design and uh
you know uh can bring that sense of
wonder back to it I I have one example
that I I like to point out is I like
Hitchcock because he's playing in this
very playful way of Mastery with uh all
these things with fairy tale spooky
things scary things Shadows and Light
um but he will often deliberately leave
a gap in his explanation of things like
in one of his movies notorious Cary
Grant is a spymaster who's trying to get
Ingrid Bergman to help him to seduce
some Nazi spies and get their secrets
and
um you know there's something weird
about Cary Grant in the way that he
deals with women and the uh wonderful
love that she's offering to him she was
pleading with him please forget about
the spy stuff let's run away and uh you
know we're obviously meant for each
other so why don't we just skip all this
dangerous spy stuff and he sticks to his
duty but he's unusually weird about
romantic things about kissing and uh
all all the stuff that you would think
would be automatic for Cary Grant and
Hitchcock just refuses to tell you why
that is so it invites me as an audience
member to fill in that blank and the
missing piece that I've filled in is
that Cary Grant was a spy during World
War II and he had a lover who was also a
spy and she betrayed him and he had to
kill her and that's not in the script
but it's very attractive uh solution for
me for this mystery that Hitchcock
allows to just dangle there he doesn't
uh draw attention to it nor does he uh
spend any time explaining it but uh it
it added to my delight and my pleasure
in the film now that film is mine
because I wrote part of it you know and
I think the audience enjoys sometimes
when there is a disjuncture in the story
or there's a missing piece they get a
big kick out of filling it in and
imagining that for themselves this is
the whole world of fan fiction which is
a wonderful development that people love
the story so much that they'll write in
these kind of explanations and
backstories that the original creators
didn't provide
what's the purpose of a character's
death in a story
good question what is the character's
death what does that do for the story
what is the purpose of that well death
magnifies death uh elevates a story and
I would say
in your cast of characters
death should be one of the characters
who comes around who threatens
um
or who actually steps on stage and Deals
out death to someone you know like the
figure of death with the scythe and the
hood
that we see in cartoons all the time
um
yeah that uh is an important and I think
even mandatory element to have in a
story and I don't mean that literally
necessarily although it's great if it's
there as a threat or an actuality
um
but the possibility of death or failure
is the metaphorical way to look at it
that it's the death of the possible
death of your hopes the possible death
of your dreams
that's I think operative in that Cary
Grant's notorious example that he's
hoping for his belief in love to be
restored but he's really dubious about
it because death got in the way in the
past and death is threatening now so
there's a tension between those forces
but the death of a character
maybe the thing that makes it into a
worthy story that the hero uh either
dies or experiences death quite nearby
someone near and dear to them dies or
they are forced to deal death to someone
else that's a traumatic thing that
sometimes can be quite a powerful
movement in a story and maybe they feel
responsible or they uh
blame themselves
but the death helps to elevate the story
and and is almost a necessity in order
to really
shake the audience and and communicate
with them that this is quite a serious
it is a matter of life and death
should death serve the plot or the
themes or both
well yes death should serve
um
both the plot and the themes it kind of
works almost in a mechanical way within
the plot
but we haven't talked about themes much
but uh the theme I think there should be
one overriding theme in most stories
there can be multiple ideas but uh one
basic human quality that you're
exploring and death should definitely
lean over that and cast a shadow on
whatever that human quality is if you're
talking about uh Brotherhood or loyalty
or friendship or trust
um that should be threatened
and you know that would be your theme is
I'm going to talk today about ambition
well what if your ambition is thwarted
by death or failure
that would add gravity to the story and
maybe shine some light on uh on the
theme by testing it severely to the
point of death
so those things can all work together to
make it a nice design what impact does
the death of the hero have on other
characters in the story oh that's a
great thing when the hero dies or
appears to die there is an impact on
everybody else in the story
the great example that brought this to
my attention as a young film student
when I was looking for the hidden rules
and had just found them in the work of
Joseph Campbell so there's the whole
pattern then I went to see the first
Star Wars movie which came out within a
few days after reading Campbell for the
first time and by golly there everything
was but in the critical scene in the
middle of that movie that corresponds
from me to the ordeal stage eight in my
frame
um is that they're in this giant trash
Masher thing at the bottom of the Death
Star and Luke Skywalker our hero is
Pulled Under by something with tentacles
and appears to uh have died not for long
but for just a few frames you see
bubbles come up and then no bubbles the
water goes flat and then the attention
turns away from him to all the other
characters who are watching and they are
freaking out because they think the
evidence is telling them Master Luke is
dead he's been pulled to his death and
so they're all thinking how am I going
to go on and who's going to be the hero
now and I sitting in the audience am one
with them wondering
if I'm not Luke Skywalker anymore who am
I in this movie I identified with him
I'm going through the story wanting what
he wants and now if he's dead
who am I so there was this sense of
unease and uh a sense that something's
been pulled out of the design and it
creates a vacuum and I think that's uh
embedded in
um a lot of ancient rituals
uh that go back to the Stone Age times
when to escape from the ice sheets from
the glaciers we had to go into caves in
Europe they acted out these kind of
scenes where
the shaman or the leader of the ceremony
would take on the Robes of a buffalo or
something and would dance around and
then would seem to die it's it's like
built in it's like baked into
ritual
performances that
you will enact the life of the
characters of of these Supernatural
forces like the Buffalo Spirit or
something like that but also their death
and the audience
um is programmed or trained to react by
Crying by you know holding themselves
tight and worrying oh what's going to
happen to us now that we don't have a
hero to protect us they gather around
the sort of pit where the hero has
fallen in and are deeply affected by it
and depressed
and this is part of the magic of the
hero's journey is that then that figure
the robed uh Shaman who's playing the
role of the Buffalo or Luke Skywalker
comes back to life
sort of defying our expectations and our
understanding of death is permanent
so if someone appears to die they're
dead and then they come back again wow
we get a supernatural Boost from that it
gives us a lift and this is sort of the
inner mechanism of uh all stories I
think and all religious rituals and all
kind of performances of of any kind is
to take you to that edge let you
experience that for a few moments and
then bring life back into the picture
and it transforms you it you don't come
back to the same level
it's like if you took a basketball and
pushed it down under the water
um
it's
resisting you it wants to come back up
to the surface and if you just suddenly
let go of it it doesn't just Bob up to
the surface it actually flies up out of
the water
so the same thing is happening with
human emotions that when you depress
them by apparently killing the hero by
making me think the hero has died
the audience's emotions are temporarily
depressed and they'll go along with it
even though they know I've seen the
movie before and I know Luke Skywalker
doesn't die here he's going to live but
just for that second part of you on this
cave person level
experiences it as if it were real
and feels all the things that you would
feel if someone dear to you had died
so then they're brought back to life and
there's this huge rush
and there's a lift and this can be done
a number of times in the course of a
story should be I think somewhere in the
middle and then certainly just before
the end we replay this at stage eight
and Stage 11
where the hero is resurrected and uh you
know the art of the Storyteller and the
filmmaker is to make the death as
convincing as possible or to make the
failure as convincing as possible
and then turn it so that the hero wins
and we get so much more satisfaction out
of that than we would if the hero just
did the things in one uh if they did the
things and fell into a pit and almost
died or seemed to die to all appearances
they've died and then they crawl out
alive that's a tremendously more
powerful experience than just you know
doing some task and succeeding
so I I think the death
serves to involve the audience because
they're all you know existentially
concerned about their own death so
anytime you show me one on on screen uh
part of me is studying that quite
closely to see what's it going to be
like for me and maybe there's hope that
I can live through it and live again is
there such a thing as a hero's death or
a villain's death
yeah there's there is uh uh room for the
hero's death uh and for the villain's
death
um in these designs uh this is uh
something you can trace this back all
the way to the beginnings of
Storytelling if you want to go back in
let's say Anglo-Saxon literature you can
look at Beowulf Beowulf was this great
uh warrior hero who fought monsters he
fought one Monster uh
battled with this thing tore its arm off
and then had to fight its mother who
came to get revenge
and then defeated that one and lived a
long time
ruling over his people and having
prosperity and good times but in the end
had to face one more Monster and there
comes a dragon
that is uh it's a terrific battle but in
the end they both go down in flames and
so the hero dies in sacrifice and that's
a common way for uh the death of a hero
to be experienced it can be experienced
tragically uh there's certainly lots of
room for that in many many stories that
end with the tragic death of the hero
and maybe it's meaningless and that
itself is a sad thing that you died for
nothing
but there are other cases where the
hero's sacrifice is Meaningful and it
was done to save others
or to show some way that maybe I
couldn't make it but you can this is
kind of the idea in the Bible where
Moses gets to the edge of the promised
land and he's within sight of it but
he's just too old and so he says you go
on to the promised land and I'm just
gonna camp out here and watch you all go
and I'll wave goodbye and we know he he
dies soon after
so the hero sometimes is handing it off
and uh leaving it for others to finish
and that's a noble death when the hero
sacrifices something or gives it over to
the Next Generation
as for the villains the villain's death
is a different kind of satisfaction
there is a thing called Poetic Justice
which means that whatever the hero or
the villain did they should be rewarded
or punished in a way that matches
poetically to what they did so if the
hero did something dangerous and
wonderful to save the world they should
be rewarded with love with
the crown you know with being King with
some kind of prize
some kind of Victory and if they have
failed if they have broken the rules of
the gods or have let themselves down and
let the others down then it's a tragic
kind of thing but for the villains there
should be this poetic justice so that
whatever evil thing they did to the hero
the same should be done to them a
beautiful example of this is in The
Wizard of Oz where Dorothy deals with
this wicked witch who's already set her
straw man friend on fire
and is threatening to kill her and her
dog and everybody in the team
and uh Dorothy does an act of Mercy she
takes a bucket of water and throws it on
the wit on on the Scarecrow and puts out
that fire but some of the water goes on
and splashes the Witch and Dorothy
doesn't know this but the witch is in
the book she's it says she's made of
sugar and that she just dissolves and
goes down into the floor crying out you
know my wonderful wickedness is is over
and uh so the villain's death gives us a
satisfaction that it sort of corrects
the imbalance the villain represents an
imbalance in society and the hero is
trying to bring things back to a state
of balance to a state of justice and so
it might be necessary to uh
punish the villain in accordance with
what they did it's very unsatisfying if
they get away with something and don't
have to pay an appropriate price for
what they did
audiences on some level just
instinctively know that's not a happy or
satisfying ending
do you think you know know you talked
about going to the film School in
Denmark or working with the Danish
students certain cultures have less of a
return with the Elixir at the end just
as as in life that doesn't always happen
oh I'm glad to talk about the
differences from culture to culture
because this really just came up and hit
me like I'd stepped on a rake or
something
when I first started traveling I found
that I was carrying with me a bag of
cultural assumptions that came from
growing up in the midwest
I lived on a farm most of my childhood
and my diet was entirely Old Warner
Brothers movies and cartoons and what
was on television then so Superman and
Zorro and things like that
and there were a lot of cultural
assumptions embedded in that like the
hero is a good Force the hero can change
things the hero can save us uh the hero
uh usually is unselfish and uh is has
the best interests of society in mind
and as soon as I got out of the frame of
the United States of America I started
meeting all these other ideas that uh
for instance in Eastern Europe they
would say to me
um yeah you mentioned these characters
who think they can change the world and
who think one person can make a
difference we actually have some of
those but we don't call them Heroes we
call them fools and idiots because
nobody can really change the world it
just is how it is and
um you know you're foolish if you think
you can you can mark the system
so I began to understand that I needed
to broaden my ideas and some cultures
were just outright uh disapproving of
the term hero and I've noticed that some
people like the screenwriting teacher in
Denmark had
clipped out the word hero and he just he
didn't teach the hero's journey he
taught the journey
and I think that was actually a wise
move because it does away with a lot of
cultural baggage that we have about
heroes uh you know when I first started
teaching about it people assumed oh
you're talking about male Heroes because
when we say hero we usually mean a male
hero and I said no no no that's that's
not the way I mean it it could be any
gender it couldn't even be genderless
being animal or uh you know spirit
so don't get hung up on on gender or you
know their natural equipment but
um
I I began to see that I needed to
broaden my view of things and so
different cultures have different
emphasis uh we in the west tend to
gravitate towards stories that have a
single hero or at most what they call
the two-hander where there will be two
people like it my buddy type story or a
romance where the two are kind of
balanced equally but a lot of cultures
don't acknowledge stories like that at
all and they only think a story is
something about a whole Community or a
group or a family and
um
so I I've had to do some editing of my
thoughts and try to to get closer to a
world view rather than my own cultural
view it still has value and it certainly
translates uh around the world everybody
kind of gets the Hollywood model and
they copied a lot of places but it's
very healthy that they reject it in some
ways and have their own standards and
and Views about that and I'm fine with
that sure because I think In some
cultures it's considered a bad thing to
stand out what is it the the nail that
is the highest gets hammered down
there's different uh sayings so yeah but
in ours we're seduced by the the
individual who takes the reins and
Against All Odds and Rises up against
the crowd so that's right we hold it up
as some high value that somebody uh puts
their hand up they volunteer they stick
out of the crowd uh they're you know
rugged individuals or something like
that but as you say in other cultures uh
the base assumption is no we're all the
same here mate as they told me in
Australia they said we have something
called The Tall poppy syndrome that when
one poppy grows up higher than the
others somebody comes along and cuts
that off so you better keep your head
down and and you know not stand out or
not claim to be higher or better than
everybody else and I think this is a
real difference
in cultures that the Western culture
American movie culture is generally
pretty aspirational it's it's aiming for
or striving for greater achievement more
risk greater reward
um sort of selling that idea that uh you
know you don't you don't get without you
give some risk and so uh that's not
believed in every culture and and that
has to be taken into account
I don't know this this may get I'm not
trying to go political here but in in
American films too the the individual
takes on the the corporation the
government whereas maybe in some
countries that could be a death sentence
they wouldn't make it and so uh just the
the risk of of how we may appear
um
to Brash or I'm foolish I don't know
where I'm going with this but yeah I
think that there's a tendency
um in Western culture and Hollywood
movie making to think that unless the
story involves somebody who steps up and
who does the extraordinary thing who
takes the great risk uh then that's a
story not worth telling and
um I have just seen a documentary I'm
sorry I can't remember the name of it
but it had something to do with people
who were running bird rescues in India
and they had this certain kind of bird
of prey called a it's a scavenger really
called a kite and the kites were just
dropping out of the sky because of
pollution and so these two men brothers
had decided that that was their mission
in life was to rescue these birds and
give decent burial to the ones who died
and nurse the other ones along
and the end of the story was actually
quite hopeless and it painted this uh
sad picture of uh a world where their
little efforts were not making any
difference at all uh
and and the forces of the world were
converging more and more so that there
would be less and less of these birds
and uh more problems uh but there was
something
although is very sad there was something
Noble about it the fact that they were
trying anyway uh and so it was a a
challenging thing to me from my Western
perspective because I kept hoping that
they would have a breakthrough or that
they'd get a government grant or that
they'd somehow you know turn around this
pollution situation but they they didn't
uh give me that and uh that was okay
because I uh felt something
that I don't normally feel which is this
sense of Despair that there are certain
things going on in the world we can't do
anything about
um but isn't it wonderful when somebody
tries
so you got a little bit of both views
with that one and uh I think that's the
balance we look for
um you know a totally Grim outlook on on
life is hard that's hard to watch for
anybody in any culture but um
the balance is what I think is healthy
what is symbolism
well I think symbolism is a way
of making invisible things visible
uh that's uh a concept I guess that I
learned from observation of Alfred
Hitchcock's work because he uses a lot
of
things in the environment are in a
symbolic way
sometimes it's an object that represents
uh some idea that he's trying to
transmit sometimes it's simply
environmental things like sounds or
Shadows he will do little things like if
someone is trying to decide if they're
going to do something or not if they're
going to be involved in a spy plot or
something like that he sometimes will
sneak in a little train noise on the
soundtrack just a little
like some the train is leaving are you
going to be on the train so he's giving
you subliminal messages
um that you might think is it just
random sound but in fact it's totally
intentional and so uh it's his way of uh
bringing out this other dimension the
people are talking they're doing things
there's action but they're also feeling
things and there are forces
in the story uh that are almost
operating like gods or fairies sometimes
you get that feeling in Hitchcock's
movies that he himself is a puppeteer
manipulating things or that there is
some kind of
malign God who's looking out for these
people or
laughing at them
uh so the symbols help to convey those
things
uh but I think that's the key to it is
that symbols are a way of making
invisible
ideas feelings Concepts visible to the
audience
and uh
it's quite wonderful the way you can
just show me something like a glass of
water
and I'll start if you emphasize it in
the frame and just Linger on it for a
second I'll start thinking well what
does that mean is that what is that a
symbol of well the glass is half empty
so maybe this character is at that point
and they need to fill the glass or they
need to drink or the glass is maybe
going to break and you know it will mean
something in the text of the story and
we're so ready to do that
um that it makes it quite easy for
filmmakers to assign these things and it
doesn't have to be even a thing it could
be a color or a sound
sometimes a good filmmaker will will use
a color to Signal you something bad is
going to happen or uh don't go there you
know that every time you see the color
green perhaps something bad happens and
if after that sequence of cause and
effect happens two or three times every
time the audience sees green they're
going to be scared and they'll they'll
know on some deep level they'll know
that this is trouble coming
so this is one of the ways that that
symbols can be used and and the audience
uh enjoys playing with those toys you
know uh with imagining what is what does
that mean what does that symbolize
so it's almost like um pavlovian there's
a you they're starting to train you so
you salivate when you're the Bell kind
of thing it is it is like a Pavlov's dog
sort of response that we pick it up very
quickly that uh if you see an evil
character cooking uh you know that's
what he does just before he kills
somebody so after one or two examples of
that the next time you see him cooking
you're just waiting or who's gonna die
you're looking around for uh who is he
coming after next
so it is it is fairly easy to program
the audience with little cues like that
it's a lot of fun to find those things
you talk about the
pasm in myths and how symbols
communicate Universal truths
yes symbols in myths have their own
peculiar power
I think this started uh around what they
call attributes in you know the
scholarship of Greek gods and goddesses
every god and goddess has certain
objects or animals that are associated
with them and when we see that object or
that symbol
we might suspect that God is nearby or
that that the hero maybe is under the
influence of that god or goddess
Athena for example who's a goddess of
wisdom has a number of things that
are associated with her in art so when
you make a picture of her or a sculpture
or something
you include those things and it helps
tell the audience oh that's Athena but
because she has an owl on her shoulder
which is a symbol of wisdom she has a
certain
piece of armor on her chest that's
called the Aegis that protects her she
has a helmet pushed back on her head
that represents that she's a warrior
goddess and she sometimes has a spear
and so forth so all those things are
Clues to that character's presence or
that God's presence
but also can kind of move around
independently of them so when the owl
comes by you know Athena is watching out
uh this is a uh an idea that comes out
in Scandinavian mythology uh that uh the
god Odin uh has his own attributes and
tools and weapons and so forth but one
of the things he's associated with is
two Ravens who sit on either side of his
throne and they're always going out and
flying around and gathering information
and then they'll come back and tell him
what's going on uh on Earth so when you
see Ravens circling around you know Odin
is nearby and they actually put this
into the text of the Vikings TV show the
HBO series that every time the Ravens
show up you know Odin is paying
attention and the hero has you know
maybe access to that at that point
so the these symbols help
to suggest what what is the energy at
that moment are we under some dark
dangerous influence uh or are is is some
God looking out for us
and sending their messenger in the form
of one of these animals or just an
object that represents them
sure and then with the the quote unquote
villain uh there was always fear of the
witch's familiars the cats or different
uh rats or sometimes even Raven suit
doing the evil bidding for the witch
when he or she wasn't there yeah you
know these animal uh familiars or animal
Sidekicks are very useful when I was
working for Disney we were developing
the movie that eventually became Aladdin
and this was very early in the
development Aladdin was kind of uh
immature Street kid
and he was a solo act he was like in the
original Top Gun kind of a guy who
didn't need anybody else was not a team
player and as it developed
he got a little more mature
they had a different idea of
the ideal person to play that more of a
more like Tom Cruise
but uh I said in the sessions discussing
all this it would be so nice if the hero
had somebody to talk to or somebody who
could go with him on the adventures and
observe and comment and I said it could
be a camel or it could be a monkey or
something and the animators went monkey
and started drawing the hero's sidekick
a monkey and then I said well maybe the
villain needs one too
so they created this character Iago who
was this harsh voiced parrot who sat on
the villain's shoulder and the villain
was very serious but this other
character was the humor of the piece so
the monkey didn't talk he made noises
but he couldn't speak but he let he let
you know what he thought about things
and we kept going with this and I think
I and some other animators had the same
idea at the same moment which is well
he's got this Magic Carpet why can't we
animate that why shouldn't that be a
character with its own expressive
abilities and the animators went wow
that's great and immediately started
drawing pictures of the the rug uh
waving hello or shrugging or crossing
the two corners to cross its arms
disapproval uh you know they they found
this whole vocabulary for a piece of
carpet and and turned it into a
character who added Dimensions to the
story so uh I I've enjoyed uh you know
making that that contribution that isn't
in the original uh Source stories of
Aladdin or any of those Arabian Night
stories but uh you know that's that's my
little pleasure is to have planted some
of those things
what is a shaman and why do you say a
shaman is one of the most original of
all artists ah yes well Shaman is uh
it's a word that has grown Way Beyond
its Origins it was originally used uh by
uh
so-called native people uh in Siberia
regions and now it's been expanded to
mean any kind of Wise Old healer of the
tribe anybody who takes charge of uh
magical uh operations within the tribe
who blesses things
sometimes they curse things or people
but they are the holders of the esoteric
knowledge the knowledge of the unknown
or the other Spirit worlds
and um they are known for
traveling to these other worlds by
various means they have access to them
in a way that Ordinary People don't and
usually they have arrived at this
condition
through some catastrophic event in their
lives it's very common that people will
discover that they are meant for this
Shaman creative role
because of some catastrophe in their
life
many of the old ones in the the tribes
used to write about or tell about
being attacked by a bear or something
like that and really malled up and
chewed and almost at death's door but
that process of being chewed up broken a
lot of Bones broken and so forth allowed
them to reassemble in a different way
and it's almost like they became
radio receivers or Crystal sets that
could receive the Transmissions of this
other world and many uh
anthropologists have collected stories
about these people who also say that
they have a certain particular kind of
dream that guides them to be uh a shaman
or a Healer of the tribe they call them
uh in anthropology they call them the
wounded healers because often they do go
through some kind of near-death
experience
either in reality or in their dreams and
so these are the original artists I
think I I think that these things happen
spontaneously a long long time ago
but that we can see evidence of it in
the cave paintings that have survived
for forty thousand years in some cases
you see images of people dressed up in
the skins of animals Dan dancing and
obviously doing some kind of magical
operations
in the disguise of animals and that's
part of their deal is that often they
will form a relationship
with a particular animal that's
important to the tribe maybe that you
know they live on the deer or they live
on the Buffalo and so somebody needs to
be the mediator between the Buffalo and
the human beings and you know understand
if the Buffalo all have gone away where
did they go and what can we do to bring
them back so the shamans sometimes have
that
function that job to do to bridge the
gap or if there's something wrong in the
society like all the water has dried up
the the streams aren't running anymore
the shamans sometimes will put a rug
over his or her head and just meditate
for a while and travel to these other
worlds to the spirit world and they're
the spirits tell them well you have to
go up to the source somebody has to go
up to the spring and see what's gone
wrong up there and then they March up
there and they find that well trees have
fallen in and the the way for the water
is blocked so we have to on we have to
clean the drains and we have to open uh
the the water so that it can flow again
or we have to do something to make peace
with the animal world or with the spirit
world nature world and the shamans often
will bring
uh that message in a form that we
recognize as creativity dances songs
stories images they'll make images of
gods and goddesses uh masks that allow
people to get a little taste of this
other world or they'll bring back from
the spirit world they'll bring back a
dance and have everybody do the dance
and it has the effect of bringing people
together and healing whatever was out of
balance so they're they're the natural
balancing agents that bring the Two
Worlds into a happy harmonious
relationship at least that's the ideal
so then current artists are we are we
broken individuals trying to make
ourselves whole
through our art I think every artist
recognizes a little bit of this shamanic
uh heritage
because
you don't get to be an artist by being
happy and by being uh
unconcerned about things or having no
problems to deal with in life you would
be a pretty boring artist if you came
from that background and that approach
it doesn't mean that you have to suffer
to be an artist
but you have to understand and have
experienced
some of the darker side of life so that
you can interpret it and deal with it
convincingly to other people
so I think it's it's part of the kind of
common idea about artists is that they
they suffer and if they haven't suffered
enough they're not going to be a very
good artist so there is some truth to it
although I wouldn't say go out and make
yourself miserable if you want to be an
artist it'll you don't have to worry
about that it'll come to you you know so
don't go seeking for trouble
but yeah I think this shamanic thing is
it's something that came up for me
uh when the pandemic hit
uh I didn't know what to do as a kind of
artist or somebody who kind of ministers
in a way to artists
um and then I thought well then the
thing to do is the shamanic thing which
is to go inward
and so I went for a series of long walks
alone and uh tried to
open myself to okay Universe you've
thrown us this gigantic curve how are we
supposed to respond to it and uh
if there are such Spirits I think they
speak to us when we ask them and I asked
and the answer that I got in my mind uh
was go Inward and all artists should
really go to work now to make Works to
interpret this and to help people and
heal people because the world needs it
very badly
so that's my my orientation to the
shamanic obligation
is when things are out of balance that's
the artist and the Shaman's job to give
people
metaphors in the form of songs dances
stories uh art that allows people to
compare their own situation to that of
the characters in the song The Dance the
story The Art and
take lessons from that
in a kind of safe way you know where you
you aren't experiencing it yourself but
you're seeing pretty drastic things go
on and uh if you're smart you'll take
lessons from that
sure that's interesting that you said uh
experience it yourself because it almost
sounds like a a method actor in some
ways where the dark side of that is then
you can take on
the dark energy or the sadness
of others
in trying to help
yeah you know I think there are dangers
and warnings
to be observed here you know that you
you are dealing with very very intense
forces uh within yourself
and that just exists around us
and as an artist you open yourself up to
that
but you also are obligated I think to
maintain a very strong sense of yourself
because it would be easy to get lost
and to uh
find yourself tempted by the power that
is offered by these things
I I'll just say this that in the early
development of my ideas I had a kind of
a shamanic experience where I had worked
very hard on a paper for class just a
term paper about Star Wars and close
encounters and this Joseph Campbell
hero's journey idea and put it all
together and stayed up a couple of
nights doing all-nighters as students
will do and I was in an exhausted state
of mind after turning in the paper the
next day and something hit me I had some
kind of a shamanic experience where I
felt that my mind was being
crystallized along different lines and
and where I might have seen things like
a cube before simple uh you know six
sides and a few angles all of a sudden
it was uh some complex geometric shape
like a dodecahedron that has 12 faces
and is very complex with lots of
interactions
so uh
in in that process I felt I was
communicating with
the spirit world
and this is all in my head I'm not like
seeing visions or anything I'm just
thinking
and it was as if there was a crowd of
nurses or doctors around me who were
saying ah there's a live one here's a
guy who's kind of tuned into this stuff
and uh
we can offer him a deal here
that you can use this material this idea
of the hero's journey any way you want
you can start a new religion you could
run the world you could do all sorts of
things create a very successful business
out of it if you want Market it
or use it benevolently to heal the world
you know it's up to you and I thought
for just a second and I said well if we
have the choice let's make the world a
little bit better place let's use this
to tune things up make it better and
those Spirits in my mind said good
choice and we will support you in that
and So you you're gonna have to work
hard don't get the wrong idea but we
will look out for you and if you keep
the positive view of this forward and
you make it with that intention that
this is for good then we'll support you
and and all will be well so and that's
really been borne out in in my career I
certainly have had to work hard but I've
always felt backed up by that original
choice and by those
Spirit guides so I I take the shamanic
thing pretty seriously as a real thing
for me
what is the creative writing process and
how is it different from other writing
processes well I've done uh
a variety of
jobs worn different hats as Under the
Dome of the writer some of my work was
sort of journalistic
some of it was critical and some of it
is pure creative and they are very very
different hats and even within the
creatives there are different hats so to
speak like if you want to write comedy
you've got to put on a comedy hat you've
got to be you know tuned to look for the
opportunities to be funny or if you're
writing something scary you put on the
scary hat
and you look for those opportunities but
it's it's quite a different thing
to write critically as I did for most of
my career the bulk of my career I was a
kind of a threshold Guardian actually
one of those archetypes whose job is to
say no it's not good enough most of the
time
so we were reading uh individually the
people like me were reading maybe 10
scripts a week
maybe 12 scripts a week and 11 of those
for sure would be
a pass meaning no it's not good enough
it's not ready it's not right for this
studio but every once in a while maybe
one out of 15 or 20 you'd go maybe this
could be turned into something or yes
I'm sticking my neck out for this and
um it's hard to say which of the hats
you're wearing at that point as a reader
of Scripps as a professional analyst of
scripts I had to read as if I were
creating a movie I was an act of the
imagination
and I had to take the roles of the
cinematographer and the director and the
sound guy and the
music supervisor and I had to provide
all that and inflate this thing that's
all flattened out on 120 pieces of paper
inflate that into a a full movie as best
as it could be realized you know I tried
to make it the best production of this
even if the script was horrible I tried
to make it the best produced version in
my head so there was a creative act
involved there
um but then you have to get down to uh
the job of explaining why this works and
why that doesn't work and why this would
be good and why that you shouldn't
bother and so forth which is quite
different from the uh the writing the
pure creative writing hat uh I I like
that hat a lot
um because
you are in God's chair in a way there
even more than as a reader Imagining the
thing you're completely responsible for
this room that I'm imagining the every
chair in it every person in it every
wall hanging every ever you're
responsible for everything and uh and it
has to mean something and that isn't
easy
so that's a whole other set of tasks but
I I like using
both sides I think it has something to
do with the sides of the brain that the
analytical side is you know off to one
side and the other is the the more
purely creative they overlap but uh but
I like that the free full creative thing
too
the relationship between creativity and
Imagination
oh interesting what's the relationship
between creativity and Imagination well
I would start with imagination
because uh I think that's when I first
became aware of the possibilities here I
had just been I was maybe five years old
and I had just been read some fairy tale
by my grandmother about a giant it was
probably Jack and the Beanstalk
and the next day I remember so vividly I
was looking out the back window into our
backyard and there was a big uh hedge
that was the end of the yard and on the
other side was Wilderness in a farm and
you know wild animals and snakes and all
kinds of stuff I didn't ever dare go in
there
um but I'm sitting in this thought of
the giant ran through my mind and I saw
with my imagination a gigantic boot come
down and crash into the yard and I
realized and I jumped back
you know because my imagination had so
thoroughly created that thing
that it was it might as well have been a
giant stepping down into my yard and so
I realized wow imagination is I mean I
actually physically jumped back
because my imagination had done such a
good job of creating that so uh that's
uh my sort of starting point for it and
then the creativity is uh all the things
that you bring to bear
to realize your imagination uh like what
do they say what does it look like how
does it smell taste feel using all the
senses uh those those are things that
come out of uh I think the aftermath of
the imagination that you dream something
up and then you use your creativity to
express it that's how I'm seeing it
today anyway so
and I think you've said as a viewer if
uh at least two of your vital organs
don't respond to a story then it that
it's not really a compelling story yeah
that's a real deep belief of mine that
um this stuff of stories
acts upon the human body more than the
human mind the mind is involved the
imagination is involved of course
but I think this was a belief that
Joseph Campbell had that the images in
the myths Were Somehow programmed to
bypass the brain and the intellectual
function you can still use it but you're
actually being affected below the neck
mostly in the organs of the body and
that's a rule of mine that if two or
more organs of the body are not
secreting fluids or squirting or you
know generating tears or causing the
chemicals in the neck to choke up or
making the heart beat faster all those
are injections of chemicals by these
organs of the body which are somehow
mysteriously programmed to respond if we
see a fireman pick up a baby and carry
it out of the fire
something goes on inside you and makes
you tear up or choke up or makes your
heart swell so I'm a big believer in the
the power of these things and that they
actually operate below the level of the
brain processing it joins in too but
it's more about uh the uh direct effect
on on the organs of the body
if the path before you is clear you're
probably on someone else's Carl Young
quote how does this relate to the hero's
journey and storytelling wow I I don't
remember hearing this before this is
Carl Jung saying if the path before you
is clear you're probably on somebody
else's path
um yeah I write in the last chapter of
my book The Writer's journey I write
about uh an event in my life that I call
trust the path where uh I was lost in
the woods basically and and in in some
danger of getting uh in trouble from you
know being wet and cold and exposure
uh and uh
I
came out of it
with a kind of shamanic experience there
um in the woods that told me this phrase
trust the path
and I really had to think about that a
lot and Jung's quote brings out some
thoughts about it uh you're you're on a
path and I say you should trust that
path
and
um you can get hung up on the fact of
well if there's a path other people have
gone and I'm just following
but I don't think that's the case I
think the real situation is
um
you may be following a path that others
have taken and that others will take
after you but nobody sees it the way you
do you have a unique View
and that view is valuable
so everybody's experience of the journey
is going to be a little different and
you might stop and take a picture in the
same spot others have taken
but your intention and your background
and your wishes for the future all those
things make a difference and should give
you the sense that you know my view is
worthy my view is worth something and I
I say that to people uh as my kind of
parting shot I say uh
please tell your stories because the
world needs them and we need your
particular story your particular
Viewpoint because it's Unique nobody
else sees it the way you do and that
itself has value so I I say to writers
and creators
that you should
you should not be discouraged because
things have been done before others have
uh you know painted before others have
sung songs before
so what it wasn't yours and yours is
special
so I I kind of leave people with that as
my Parting Shot is trust the path
and especially your path because it's
Unique